[Music]
the uk continues to lead
europe on the scale and efficiency of
the vaccine roll out
of course it's in our interest that
everybody in europe and elsewhere is
vaccine is vaccinated but it's
good to see britain doing something
right and who better to break down the
significance of the numbers
than professor david spiegelholter he's
a statistician
at statistician and chair of cambridge's
winton center
for risk and evidence communication
professor
welcome back to spectator tv let me
begin with a general question
is it right in your view to to see
uh vaccine policy in some ways is now
the government's major economic policy
i without this vaccine i mean heaven
knows what how would be able to get out
of this
this epidemic especially with the new
variants coming along
so it must go absolutely hand in hand
with
opening up society and the rebuilding of
the economy
and and that's why the comparisons
between what's happening in the uk and
what's happening
certainly in the rest of europe become
so interesting
tell us where we are with the vaccine
now
i as i understand it quite early on the
british government
obviously taking scientific advice
deciding that it would give priority to
getting as many
of the target groups as possible the
first dose
it knew we'd need a second dose and
weeks later but the idea was
rather than doing the first then the
second to do as many first first first
as possible
and then follow up with the second that
i think has been a vindicated
strategy there were three bold decisions
made at the beginning of the vaccine
rollout
and strongly influenced by the
scientific opinion from
from jcvi the the committee responsible
the first in terms of the prioritization
which is strictly based on a statistical
analysis
of who is most at risk and so there's a
absolute clear objective to save the
maximum number of
lives and which is also the number of
years of life lost as well so complete
focus on that and that are two
implications three implications
first of all who got the vaccine first
secondly
that they wanted to get as many first
jabs into as many
arms as possible with a delay on the
second dose
until 12 weeks and this was very
controversial
criticized by other other countries as
well and
and thirdly the idea that the
astrazeneca vaccine although the trials
had not
you know included many people over 65
was fine to give to over 65
those three um bold controversial
decisions
have been all been vindicated and have
led to the staggering success of our
vaccine rollout
and the clear signs of it of its
effectiveness now
now tell me who who have we done who who
is now
covered by the vaccine even if it's just
the first dose
because i think that still gives you
quite a high percentage of efficacy
uh and who's going to be next well we
work
down through you know the people in care
homes then they're in the over 80s
over 70s people on the clinically
extremely vulnerable list and so on
and so very high percentages in these
groups have been vaccinated
we're now going to the six mid 60s i got
myself done
which is great just in you know as part
of the group
and now we're working down to the first
nine groups will bring us down to
50 year olds and include and people who
um right down to 18 who have some
medical condition
so those are being done now with the aim
that those first five groups
those first nine groups will be done um
certainly by
well they've sort of said by mid april i
think but i think they could easily be
done
before that and then um obviously it has
been contested who gets it next
should it be prioritized in terms of
some occupations but it looks like
they're still deciding to
work down through the age groups and
following the scientific
uh discovery from a statistical analysis
that age is the absolutely dominant
factor
your risk of catching and dying from the
virus doubles for every six years you're
older
and so that that um i think again is a
very science-based conclusion
and that would from what you say then on
that statistical basis professor
it would probably make sense for for the
government to continue on the
trajectory that it's on in other words
being age
driven yeah i think i think that's what
what they are doing
clearly it's it's very delicate because
i can see that
certain professions we know um very
public-facing professions do have a
higher risk
but then if you were going to do that
you'd want to do taxi drivers you'd want
to do but
you know public transport jobs all sorts
of people would be then
sort of demanding uh to be to be put up
in the queue so
they have gone for essentially keeping
it quite simple i mean they should have
done men before women for example of the
same age but
you know they've tried to keep it as
simple as possible and i can understand
that
it's a bit like the tier system which
they don't want to go back to because
the complexity of that gave rise to so
many
arguments that i can see that they're
preferring to keep
things just simple and just say that's
the way it's going and i think
what's also remarkable there's no queue
jumping you cannot just get this vaccine
you cannot even
know if you it's not like getting a test
if you pay money you could get a test
i i feel really proud of that i feel
deeply moved by the way we're all
standing in our queue and we're getting
our jabs
and you can't buy it the rich can't lie
i don't think you can
i wouldn't dare anywhere on the black
market i mean who knows what would be in
the vial
exactly exactly are we getting evidence
in addition to uh preventing
uh going down with the covert
particularly going down
severely to an extent of hospitalization
the evidence for that
now assuming for the vaccine's efficacy
is quite strong
is there evidence too that it also
prevents transmission yep
it's growing now i mean unfortunately
the biggest effect
is for the nastiest things so we know
that hospitalization just from one dose
from this fantastic scottish study
showed a
85 percent reduction in hospitalizations
from us
from um pfizer 94 from astrazeneca
and i should add there's no difference
between those numbers
yes there you know it makes all
mystically there's no difference
no there's no difference at all you know
if you look at the as we statisticians
would look at the margins of error
around those numbers they completely
overlap so there's no basis for saying
one is better for the other
on the basis of that data that's
hospitalization that means
protection against dying even higher
than that
very like we still haven't not had that
many deaths following vaccination
and so uh it's very difficult we're not
too confident about assessing that
exactly but i'm sure it's above 90
percent
efficacy against against death against
infection
um against some disease it'll be
a bit lower than that it looks like
about 80 in the 80
and it gets infection maybe you know 60
to 60 70 percent
protection against infection growing
evidence for that
um and so and but it does depend on the
variant possibly
so though there is protection against
infection but
even greater protection against the more
severe outcomes which is what we're most
interested
in it it's encouraging to see britain
doing well in this given all the
mistakes that were
about to be made around this time last
year which
has set us back of course it was
uncharted territory forever
a body then but of course it it and
because you can
you know i'm sure that some people in
britain will take some a certain comfort
from the fact that europe is making a
bit of mess of things in some areas
but of course we can't really be free
until our friends in europe are also
on the same trajectory as we are and
they're quite
far behind professor i mean i'm coming
to you from france
here they've only done seven percent and
and
the president's uh attacks on
astrazeneca
uh have given the already quite a strong
anti-vax
movement in france a reason for not
taking the astrazeneca there are
as we speak uh about a million unused
astrazeneca doses this this is a
complete tragedy and
um i don't sure you know it's not very
polite to refer to a president of a
of a great country as an idiot but
really that
frankly is when he said oh it's
quasi-ineffective and over 65
was both totally wrong you know grossly
misleading
and has had apparently a big effect
people are don't want this astrazeneca
vaccine
which we're now seeing in real world is
doing fantastically well
so this is tragic this is costing
lives i mean vaccines it's not like
going into
you know super drug and deciding what
headache tablet i'm going to get
if you don't get this you're not going
to get a vaccine for some time
and so i've got relatives in italy in
their 70s
absolutely no sign of a vaccine coming
for them yet i mean this is
i think this is appalling and now you
know in britain we're working right down
to as we've heard
through younger and younger people and
this is having a huge effect
so um as as you said we want everyone to
be vaccinated
so that we can restore some confidence
in traveling and moving around
so um this is tragic and it's going to
cost a very large number of lives
in in in mainland europe i think it was
more damaging i think in france than
people even in britain realize because
attacking the astrazeneca one which is
the one that doesn't need
special cold storage unlike the fisa one
and yet france does not have a
nationwide chain
of the cold storage that could handle
the fisa so actually the astrazeneca
would have been better for them because
you don't need that uh
code storage but even what we tend to
think of professor is the more
level-headed more pragmatic germans
they've kind of gone down this route
yeah it was their regulatory agencies
the european medicines agency did
approve
astrazeneca for over 65 on the same
basis as we did
that there was no evidence that it was
not effective
and a lot of in a way indirect evidence
that it was just from what we know about
vaccines what we saw about
the immune response it generated in
older people
and and so you know in a way the pre the
precautionary approach would be
to give it to the over 65s because
otherwise this is going to cost lives
but whereas many of the national um
regulatory agencies in germany and
elsewhere
thought oh we're going to be cautious
because we haven't got evidence that it
works so we're not going to approve it
well no that you know they're having now
they're changing their minds
too late you know they they brought up
distrust in this
in this treatment and in this vaccine
and it's going to take a long time to
reverse that
that public opinion so it's a total
disaster
in terms of the processing of the
scientific evidence and the
communication
of it and as i said this country's made
you know
one mess up after after another in many
ways
but it you know it's really good at this
stage with the variant new variant
spreading
you know through now throughout the rest
of europe um that
we have at last done something right
final question uh professor for today
uh if the rollout continues to be the
success it is in the good news about the
power
the efficacy of the vaccines continues
to come in too
should the government consider a quicker
exit from lockdown
or should it just be cautious june isn't
that far away
let's not get ahead of ourselves what
would you do
you know not to ask me what what the
government should do because i'm not
going to say um
i have said uh before i you know a
number of times that
we are coming up to a massive argument
because the rate at which deaths for
example are coming down in this country
i don't think
well what you know was more better than
anyone would have predicted i think
we're going to see um obviously certain
i think now before easter
no excess deaths in this country that
the total death rate will be below
the five-year average and there will be
enormous demands to speed up the
release but i i do think
that we've got to be very cautious and i
think i i mean
they did say data not dates and then set
a whole lot of dates oh really
i mean come on no but i think you know
so i'm going to say that they should be
looking at the data
and being called let's see the result of
opening up schools
let's see the result at each step i i
mean
and and let's see what let's see what
happens and and to be cautious because
especially with the new variants coming
along there's a real risk of a of a big
blow up
where we have protected the most
vulnerable but
if if it takes off among the
unvaccinated
we could still see a huge impact on on
on their health and we'd have to then
start closing things up again
and they don't want to do that we
certainly don't professor
president we're going to have to close
up but as always it's been a pleasure
uh having you on spectator tv thank you
for joining us
today that's uh cambridge university's
david spiegel-halter
speaking to his uh one of our country's
top statisticians if not
the top statistician in fact ah i'm
still working with my abacus so i'm not
really quite in that league
[Music]
you